it just makes me upset when people
try to push the boundary millie bobby
brown
breaking down in tears after a bizarre
fan encounter
and i just wish people were more
respectful the stranger things star got
emotional on her instagram story monday
recalling how uncomfortable she felt
when a fan recorded her without her
permission while christmas shopping with
her mom
i said um no
but why would anyone want to be taking a
video of
of me you know like like it's not like
the both of us
like of me at the end of the day i don't
need to justify it to anyone
if i don't want to be taking a video of
i don't i don't have to be the 16 year
old actress said that the exchange got
intense
when the girl ignored her wishes i was
paying
and she walked past me and began to
video me again
and i said i'm a human being like what
what more do what more can i ask from
you i asked her
i asked her and she said so i can't take
a video of a human being
and i said no no when i said no it just
makes me upset when people
try and push the boundary and i just
wish people were more respectful
millie ended her video encouraging her
fans to treat others with more respect
still trying to navigate this all and
it's still overwhelming
i will take a picture with you but when
you push the boundary
and you try and fight me on it
where are my rights to say no i'm making
this video to say
you you have to show more respect for
others no matter who they are
what they do show respect human
being to human being prior to posting
that tear-filled story
the teen had deleted her tick tock
account and fans suspected that bizarre
fan
encounter may have prompted it but
millie assured everyone that she was
a-okay
writing quote i am totally fine now but
was emotional in the moment because i
felt uncomfortable and disrespected
it's important to set your boundaries
and to speak up
halfway happy of course millie first
shot to stardom in 2016 playing
11 and netflix's stranger things and the
fandom was epic from the junk
uh-oh i think we're in trouble
just check out what 12-year-old milly
told e.t back in 2017.
can we just talk about how the fans just
went completely berserk when you walk
into the red carpet
yeah they i mean they're pretty crazy i
can't wait for them to see the boys i
mean the boys are gonna be like
oh no variable ones but yes they're
incredible i love i love hanging with
them what do you think it is about the
show that everybody loves so much
i have no idea like seriously i didn't
i don't i'm just boring old milly and
they like me somehow
they like you a lot based on that
reaction yes
yeah i know pretty cool to feel though
it is incredible it's really incredible